[Music]
rejection Greg Alba here I'm John
Humphrey so we've finished fifty shades
darker it was 2:00 in the morning by the
time we finished we just shot a reaction
and review or our thoughts on fifty
shades darker than fifty shades free
trailer now many months ago oh by the
way patron of the day shout out Erica
Tuesday Erica Tuesday it's funny you
know Erica you're getting the fifty
shades darker honest trailer reaction oh
you see many months ago there was some
girl I don't remember who but she would
like tweet and then post on YouTube a
lot ever you gonna do the fifty shades
darker she kept asking the line I was
like I haven't seen fifty shades darker
so I don't want to watch the honest
trailer and now that I've seen fifty
shades darker many months after the last
time she commented whomever you are you
know who you are I'm sticking to my
promise I might be late as hell to my
promise but I'm here to watch fifty
shades darker Cheyenne
you can buy a target because she loves
entire movie
you ain't seen nothing yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sweet Jesus you're wearing stockings I
have a Christian gray mixtape in the
guise of a high-end iPad I do hope
you're not overly fond of these pendants
letters through there with his a deaf
[ __ ] and they disagree in his hands
[Music]
[Music]
Kinki 3i sweet can you give three I
can't believe you said that
iolite or Kiki was like that raisin we
said it at the same 50/50 chance the
[Laughter]
ccwg do I get the reference they put up
that moment where you know Christian
knows about her bank account details and
the way this scene ended I was like
waiter they just making it like it's
funny that he has make account details
they brush past a lot of stuff that's
like dude these are clear signs that the
guy really hasn't changed like even if
he no matter how much he suppresses it
it's coming out and I thought that's
what the movie was gonna do the whole
time I thought that's what they were
headed I was like I like the setup man
we know how messed up this guy can be
gonna snap yeah and then and not except
for something shut up I will say that I
mean even other there isn't a lot of
like sex in the movie I do think that
when they are doing sexy stuff there's I
didn't I did think so it was sex there's
a lot of sexual stuff I like the whole
thing about his mom yeah but she's like
every time he opens up about anything in
the slightest way it's the most brief
information she's like I'm so glad you
opened up to me Christian
ah now let's move on
thing else and in that scene here's your
character stuff and now we're moving
right along
yeah like Anastasia just found out that
the Christians basically you know he's
really yeah oh and she's like you know
he's obviously represses therapy to
treatment he needs therapy treatment and
his sex life is tied up in that movie
what he goes down on her an awful lot he
does yeah he's really about that I don't
think we see that I feel like that's
where the the deal was struck the
Hollywood deal was struck because like
visually there's not a lot we don't see
if we don't want to Oh Christian needs
the sounders is actually compatible with
him and some therapeutic treatment so
you can also find someone who's healthy
too so yeah he has to be healthy first
uh he's got the money you know him
this is if you want it to be functional
he should work seriously a psychological
study waiting happen you know who
doesn't need therapeutic treatment who's
that
Erica Tuesday Erica Tuesday that my dear
you are definitely closer with John
Humphrey than I so John I would love to
hang out with you I think Erica is
whatever Erica's around he's like here's
a conservatism she's definitely like
your friend more than my friend
currently like I still say that you know
Erica is a friend of mine but at the end
of the day if John and I ever broke up
there's not a chance in hell she would
side with me you know that's the kind of
relationship I would say you never know
she might surprise you my that's the big
writer correct actually no Erin she's a
baker but every time I'm around Erica I
think she has a wonderful energy I love
her yeah he's got the sarcasm back with
awesome genuine ism at the same time
genuine ISM alert it's a cool balance
that she has like she could alternate
between that yeah she's warm and she's
really pretty too soon as he gets a look
at girl fifty shades darker [ __ ]
make this sexual shout out yeah you guys
start playing some like reverb eat
crappy thing and oh dude some kind of
trap Coldplay Erica would not appreciate
that no no I take it on the last time
I'm the last guy it's like her type you
know I don't know
so one way to find out Erica are you
asking her out on Darren no I have a
girlfriend she would kill me if I asked
another girl out of the day well maybe
you could be her dog that's true I don't
have to do anything with her yes is
there a half hour and then cry
intentionally pay me $20 and shout out
Erica subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell subscribe
to screen junk inators and also you know
patreon become a patreon rejected a